[Musique]
sow
t'es pas un musée lardy vous et tout
cela sur votre petit banc expliquez-moi
pourquoi vous n'êtes ni avec ses
camarades
si ni avec ses camarades là est ce que
vous êtes contre le rythme pour le
romantisme ou le contraire je suis entre
les deux justement c'est la raison
vous avez entre les deux oui qu'est ce
que ça veut dire que je pense que je
fais des chansons dont les paroles sur
12 mai dont l'air est quand même un
petit peu c'est quand vous êtes tout à
fait part au niveau salaire bien
longtemps que je ne vous ai pas entendu
en silence les enfants cio doucement
s'il vous plaît youri doucement merci
valérie s'il vous plaît vous étiez à
leur valérie ce serait gentil
asseyez-vous le plaisir à tourner en
remercie bon enfin mademoiselle hardy
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que vous
étiez ni de ce côté là mais il ce côté
là au milieu au centre
je vous connais depuis combien de temps
la nausée lardy depuis un an
vous avez quel âge maintenant 18 ans
j'avais 18 ans est-ce que vous avez la
pression à nous et l'a redit que vous
avez fait des progrès vous faites vous
même vos chansons oui votre musique et
vos paroles oui expliquez moi et bien
que j'ai l'impression je fais un peu de
progrès point de vue la fabrication des
chansons mais en interprétation je suis
pas contente de moi vous n'êtes pas en
train de vous en interprétation assez
sage beaucoup travaillé qu'est ce qui
vous gêne
est ce que c'est la timidité oui bien
sûr je le raconte une voyez vous parler
tout de suite un petit peu plus fort
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
les chansons elles sont à peu près au
point
c'est très difficile à dire aussi parce
que la question de l'accompagnement
je me compte je me comprennent pas
tellement mais vous savez que vous
accompagne oui et ça vous gêne sommes
jeunes énormément bon dites moi
mademoiselle est du point de vue alors
de l'évolution de l'inspiration est ce
que vous avez l'impression d'avoir
changé entre 17 et 18 ans
tout le monde a tellement de la console
bras vous voulez changer en
pensez vous voudriez changer comment je
ne sais pas ça je vais vous allez
évoluer
je commence à peine la chanson la
chanson s'appelle le fit avec toi
comment la fille a vu que toi la fille
avec toi ça s'adresse à un garçon je
suppose
oui qu'est-ce qu'il ya de bons moyens
peu
[Musique]
bédié
et
yeah
[Musique]
elle
soir que
je m'ennuyais de
trop penser à toi j'ai
m'en retourner
héhé
[Musique]
nous avions autrefois à pénéter jeu
très
c
toi tu que j'ai perçu
j'aurais bien du monde
c'était
[Musique]
non mais tu m'as fait déjà vu
key
je lis
la vie
avec toi
matic
que tu m'avais bien connue autrefois jeu
j'irai jeter peu de temps
j'avais trop de chagrin
je t'aime
toujours autant
[Musique]
pour toi je ne signifie rien
quel
l'été je vis là
avec toi que tu m'avais bien connue
autrefois
[Musique]
hardy qu'est ce que vous faites dans la
vie actuellement
eh bien je suis étudiante je prépare des
certificats licence d'allemand licence
d'allemand oui donc les chansons vous
hélas alors pas beaucoup qu'est ce que
ça veut dire quand elle est souvent
beaucoup de jeunes s'expriment en dix
ans et yéyé et en dans mes femmes
intrigue parce que je pense que ça veut
dire quelque chose est bien coté eu lieu
je suppose que ça veut dire oui en
anglais mais si je lis entendre avancer
comme ça mais l'interpréter will et on
me met au point qu'elles coïncident ça
doit vouloir exprimer quelque chose
qu'on ne t'a pas dire vous êtes restée
non ça dépend ça dépendra dans la
chanson la signature de faire les
chansons tristes dressing
on verra tournée vous il ya quelque
chose qui m'intrigue c'est assez curieux
vous avez mis votre chandail à l'envers
exprès parce que je pleurais trop grand
mais c'est une idée de mode saas est
jolie
[Musique]